Cancer is an abnormal growth of cells that has the potential to spread to different areas.
A tumor is just a growth of cells, which can be benign, which won't spread...
...or malignant, which is indeed cancerous.
Ninety-five percent of cancers are caused by environmental factors and only 5% from genetics.
The most common causes are obesity, tobacco, viral infections, radiation...
...and environmental pollutants.
Cancer is pretty darn scary because it can happen to anybody at any time,...
...but you can lower your chances by being overall healthy, not using tobacco or drugs...
...and getting your vaccinations.
Precancerous cells are actually somewhat common in everybody's body.
So why don't we all get cancer?
Our body has tons of defense mechanisms against it.
Precancerous cells will receive antigrowth signals, will be attacked by our immune system...
...and often go through apoptosis, which is killing themselves.
When all of these cancer defense mechanisms fail,...
...or there are too many precancerous cells for our bodies to fight off,...
...cancer will occur.
Once our bodies fail at controlling it,...
...modern medicine still has plenty of ways to fight it, though.
Chemotherapy, radiation therapy, surgery, immunotherapy and others...
...are all great ways to assist your body in fighting off the cancer.